le jour où le moule love n'aura pas une
connotation amoureuse et érotique en
français vous pouvez plus le mot amour
ne vous dira plus rien et que le mot là
vous dira quelque chose il se serait
passé quelque chose dans votre culture
tout le même
question y a-t-il eu des polémiques des
colères à bouillon de culture
probablement pas assez mais vous allez
le voir il y en a eu
c'est pas vrai que les gens parlent
comme ça dans la vie courante en
français c'est pas vrai c'est les gens
des médias qui parlent comme ça c'est
les gens de la télé qui parle comme ça
mais les gens en dehors de Paris ne
parle pas comme mais ne parle pas comme
ça c'est pas vrai
on a quelques publicitaires au Québec
qui sont efficaces aussi on est on avait
le marché beaucoup plus militantisme
c'est votre culture
français pourquoi ne les trouverez vous
pas United Benetton c'est devenu les
couleurs unies de Benetton au Québec et
personne n'a crié je veux dire il y a
personne qui dit mon Dieu
pour moi je suis désolé mais c'est ça le
problème c'est
Gémeaux en français non plus un sens
pour vous c'est que vous êtes en train
d'angliser votre pensée et
vous êtes dans
différentes entre le mot anglais et le
mot français le jour ou le mot LOVE
n'aura pas une connotation amoureuse et
érotique en français vous pouvez plus le
moins amour ne vous dira plus rien et
que le mot là vous dira quelque chose il
se serait passé quelque chose dans votre
culture tout le même
bombardier alors depuis cette colère
est-ce que les choses sont mieux que
vous étiez à l'époque est-ce que les ça
c'est améliorer alors finalement mais
vous voulez rire si ça s'est amélioré et
ben j'ai reçu avant de partir je vais
arriver avant et hier à Paris j'ai reçu
une lettre voilà j'ai un témoin d'Air
France je suis membre de fréquence plus
et la lettre est envoyée en anglais
voilà c'est ça la France maintenant et
c'est comme ça tout le temps et ce qui
était terrible dans cette émission là je
vais vous dire parce que j'en garde un
souvenir impérissable c'est que je
devais me je devais m'affirmer pour
défendre le français contre des Français
et ça je trouve que c'est terrible parce
que quand on défend la langue française
je suis devenu une sorte de de jury avec
avec Kabylie aussi toi tu es belge de
on couvre le terrain mais ça va mais il
y a une chose qui est certaine c'est que
quand on fait ça on nous regarde on
sourit n'est-ce pas on nous trouve sympa
passionné oh elle a de la pêche que je
me fais dire des fois des choses comme
ça mais on est folklorisé voilà parce
que les Français croient cher Monsieur
américain qui est ici ce soir pour
rendre hommage à la France
Les Français croient que leur langue ils
donnent le sentiment de croire que leur
langue et leur culture
ne sont pas des instruments pour définir
la modernité et ils ont ils ont une moi
j'appelle ça de la blavantisme vis-à-vis
des américains
ils ont une sorte de fascination
vis-à-vis une Amérique mythique qui
n'est pas l'Amérique réelle d'ailleurs
et je le dis on le répète les mots
français les mots anglais continuent de
pénétrer alors qu'il y a des mots
français que nous concret quand c'est
nécessaire parce qu'il faut que les mots
ça servent à quelque chose mais vous
vous avez pas de problème et puis
personne ne voit ne voit ce qui se passe
et vous croyez que votre culture qui est
la mienne et je la revendique et que
votre langue qui est la mienne et je la
revendique vous croyez que ça va c'est
de tout éternité et que vous allez
demeurer dans cette position et puis que
le Québécois qui viennent une fois de
temps en temps ici au bain il nous donne
un coup de sang et puis et puis il
retourne et puis entre temps et bien
parle anglais comme ça je fais
maintenant comme Air France le fait
comme si on le fait sur vos conseils
d'administration voilà c'est ça que je
voulais dire
[Musique]